Mr Beast is actually considering running
for president in a recent conversation
with Andrew Schultz Mr B said he'd give
the White House a shot when he turns 40
or 50. he's only 24 right now but he
already has a plan for his presidential
campaign imagine you're the average
voter and you've never heard of this 50
year old billionaire called Jimmy
Donaldson but what if that billionaire
swore to give his whole Fortune away
down to the last penny I mean that would
guarantee he only keeps the best
interest of the people in mind right but
other demographics would probably be
pretty skeptical about the whole thing
because no one has ever attempted
anything like it